نحن جميعًا نريده ونحتاجه جميعًا
ولا يحصل معظمنا على ما يكفي منه اليوم ، فنحن
نتحدث عن الشيء الوحيد الذي يؤثر على
الجميع بغض النظر عن المكان الذي تعيش فيه أو
ما تفعله وهو النوم ، فهذه
علامات حيوية
.  م د.  سانجاي جوبتا ، نقضي
ثلث حياتنا نائمين
، أي ما يقرب من 25 عامًا من
النوم ، لكن النوم ليس سوى مضيعة للوقت ،
فهو عنصر حاسم في
صحتنا ويستحق أن يؤخذ على محمل الجد
عندما يضرب رأسك الوسادة التي
لا يجديها جسمك.  لن يتم إيقاف تشغيله يستخدم هذا الوقت
لشفاء الأنسجة لتقوية الذاكرة حتى
ينمو ، لذا فإن ما يحدث عندما لا تحصل أو
لا تحصل على قسط كافٍ من النوم يمثل
مشكلة بالنسبة للكثيرين منا
ويمكن أن يؤثر ذلك على كل ساعة يقظتنا.
حول هذا الموضوع لمدة دقيقة ، كيف تنام
في الليل ، هناك الكثير لتتعلمه حول
كيفية نومنا والتأثير على طريقة عيشنا